so many online journalists and
influences and that's exactly what you
are you're journalists and your
influences come together in this
building to discuss the future of social
media each of you is fulfilling a vital
role in our nation you're challenging
the media gatekeepers and the corporate
censors to bring the facts straight to
the American people and that's what
you're doing you're going right to the
people possibly we wouldn't be here
right now I asked somebody what do you
think I'd do without social media would
I be here because I said I think so but
they weren't so sure I have to say that
you know that I'm not sure I believe
that but I have to say it but you
communicate directly with our citizens
without having to go through the fake
news filter very simple together you
reach more people than any television
broadcast network by far not even close
we're delighted to be joined at the
summit by someone you know very well our
senior advisor for digital strategy and
somebody that's been working for me for
a long time for many years dance Covino
where's Dan
[Applause]
[Applause]
so long before we were even doing this
he was at a club running a club and
other businesses and he was okay at
doing it not the greatest I wouldn't say
the greatest but you know what he was
great that he was always looking at his
computer screen I said that guy is
incredible so right at the beginning I
said that's the man and there was nobody
better at that and I think Hilary had
twenty eight people and I had Dan I had
my Dan and he works about 28 hours a day
and he works very hard he doesn't work I
mean he loves it he loves and his
imagination and and really working with
all of you and many of you he'll come up
with ideas and you'll come up with ideas
it'll run into my offices you got to see
this and a lot of times I'll go out and
I'll spend a lot of money on a concept
I'll say here's a concept come up with
this and we'll hire these companies and
they want a lot of money and they come
back just happened the other day right I
said that's terrible these guys have no
talent the people that have the talent
of the people that we deal with and it's
true and some of you are extraordinary I
can't say everybody but no but some of
you are extraordinary the crap you think
of is unbelievable
[Applause]
so I'm gonna go back to the basics of
Washington I'm going to introduce some
of my secretaries Steve minuchin Steve
where Steve Steve has done a fantastic
at Wilbur Ross well we have a meeting in
a little while on the Census and
citizenship can you believe are you a
citizen of the United States of America
sir you can't ask that question why
because the court said you can't we have
three very unfriendly courts they fight
us all the way the judges don't like us
too much I guess but think of that
Herman think of that question are you a
citizen we spend this is another thing
that's so crazy
twenty billion dollars on a census
twenty billion they spend twenty billion
it's a twenty billion what twenty
billion dollars or the census they go
through houses they go up they ring
doorbells they talk to people how many
toilets do they have how many desks do
their how many beds what's their roof
made of the only thing we can't ask is
are you a citizen of the United States
pretty amazing pretty amazing charlie
also David Bernard great job you're
doing interiors it's the largest
landlord in the United States when my
friends tell me how big they are they
get just what another building big deal
Kevin right they bought another building
then I look at David Bernard he controls
half of the United States Department of
Interior is a lot of land a lot of
beautiful land that we're taking good
care of David Wright acting director
Russ fought Russ thank you great job
we're working on our budget
along with some of the great members of
Congress and wonderful friend of mine
who's my leader right he's my leader I
tell him that to his face because it
makes him feel good I don't know if I
believe that Marsha but Kevin stand up
Kevin Kevin McCarthy everybody
senator Marsha Blackburn of the great
state of Tennessee we campaigned
together and she did we can say now she
ran against the most popular Democrat in
the last 50 years he really was great
good man right man governor for quite a
long time eight years and she just
didn't stop 12 points she was down by 10
and she won by 12 she was down by 10 and
she won by 12 and she wouldn't stop that
just every day where is she she's here
she's there fantastic job you did we're
proud of you well thank you honey that's
great it was just honestly working with
people that know what they're doing it's
fun that was fun and you know what
you're doing
representative Dan Crenshaw who is very
good at this by the way Dan
very good at this really good thank you
it's great to have you in the party and
you have more courage than I do dent
okay that courage of yours is incredible
thank you very much great job a friend
of mine and a wonderful person and
somebody that has I don't know a pretty
unlimited future I'd say I hear a lot of
very positive things Liz Cheney Liz
thank you and you know I pardon somebody
named Scooter Libby a lot of you don't
know who scooter libby is scooter
Libby's a man that got treated very
unfairly and Liz was right in the
forefront of that one and I said what do
you think Liz and you said absolutely he
deserves it and it's been a very popular
pardon he was treated very very brutally
and unfairly so thank you for that for
that help Matt Gaetz Wisman where's Matt
stand up now boy
a great defender he gets on television
and he's like it doesn't stop and he's
smart and he's good and he loves Florida
and he loves his people and he's a hard
worker and Matt thank you very much I
really appreciate it very much and Mike
Johnson Mike thank you great job Mike
and I want to thank a man who I said a
long time ago when we said let's do it
because Josh Hawley is special he is
somebody that it's Josh he got to run
well I don't know you know he had a good
set up pretty well right you weren't
going anywhere he could do whatever he
wanted at his great state and I said I'm
telling you you can do it and she turned
out she's a tough candidate whether you
like her you don't like her she's tough
right and by the end of that that was
incredible that was a hell of a race
anyone and he's young and he's brilliant
and I'm gonna ask him to come up and say
a few words if you don't mind about what
we're doing and come on up right now I
think it would be a good time
[Applause]
well first of all can we just give
another round of applause to the
president United States for his
leadership on this issue you know the
media the media says the establishment
media the fake media they say oh there's
no censorship in social media that's all
made up that's all fake you and I know
that that's not true you and I know the
truth is that the social media Giants
would love to shut us down they would
love to shut us up they would love to
shut him up more than anything else and
we can't let them and that's why we need
to step up now and I think we need to
say to them here's the deal
Google Facebook Twitter they've gotten
these special deals from government
they've gotten a special giveaway from
government they're treated unlike
anybody else if they want to keep their
special deal here's the bargain they
have to quit discriminating against
conservatives you agree with that no
more no more discrimination it's that
simple that's all we're asking for it
they ought to abide by the same
principles of free speech and the First
Amendment that this country embraces
that we love and call our own and I
don't think it's too much to ask for
these huge tech platforms who've gotten
rich off of our information right off of
our data off of everything we've given
them they've gotten rich off of it
they've gotten rich off their special
privileges from government they want to
keep those they shouldn't discriminate
they shouldn't censor they shouldn't
shut us down I want to thank the
president again for his incredible
leadership thank you for allowing me to
be here Thank You mr. president for all
that you do President Trump wants you to
know that he cares about the environment
while at the same time not really doing
anything about the number-one
environmental issue the day which is
climate change
so this week he hosted a big session in
the White House where he wanted to show
that he has an environmental track
record he can talk about with voters his
choice of words was really interesting
it shows how he's trying to thread the
needle on this issue clean air and water
have been concerns for Americans for at
least the past 50 years the issue with
climate change is quite different though
because carbon dioxide is kind of a
tougher sell for voters to really care
about it isn't a green noxious gas it
doesn't set rivers on fire one of the
interesting things about this speech is
the fact that Trump felt the need to
give it at all but when you look at the
polling underneath the headline figures
a rising proportion of younger and more
moderate Republicans do show concerns
about climate change and this is the
conundrum that trump has to deal with in
talking about clean air and water what
Trump does is politically perhaps but
then we have five different sites we
have another site with 25 million we
have another site with 10 or 12 that we
have Facebook there we have Instagram we
have a lot we have a lot of people way
way over 100 million but why used to
pick them up and I when I say used to
I'm talking about a few months ago I was
picking them up a hundred thousand
people every very short period of time
now it's I would say 10 times as long
and I noticed things happening when I
put out something a good one that people
liked right good tweet it goes up it
used to go up it would say seven
thousand seven thousand eight seven
thousand seventeen seven thousand twenty
four seven thousand thirty to seven
thousand forty four right now it goes
seven thousand seven thousand eight six
thousand nine ninety-eight then they go
seven thousand nine six thousand seventy
four I said what's going on no it never
did that before
it goes up and then they take it down
then it goes up I'd never had that this
does anyone know what I'm talking about
with this
I never had that before I used to watch
it be like a rocket ship when I put out
a beauty like when I said remember I
said somebody was spying on me that
thing was like a rocket I get a call -
two minutes later did you say that I
said yeah I said that well it's
exploding its exploding I turned out to
be right I turned out to be right we
turned out to be right about a lot of
things but but I never had it I'm just
saying from you know from the standpoint
of somebody that maybe has used social
media better than anybody judge because
I became president I'm sure I could have
done it as we said much I would have
there's no question I would have done it
either way I said to Mark Burnett the
other day I said so the apprentice had I
never done the apprentice because it was
a tremendous hit for 12 seasons I said
had I never done the apprentice would I
be President he said maybe not and I
said I think I would have but I'm always
going to say that I'm always a great
show but with social media so I've never
seen it before where I go up and then
come down up down up down now ultimately
you get but it goes very slowly but I've
never seen where it's subtracted and I
really believe people are they're taking
it up as it goes up and and it sometimes
he comes down substantially a number of
months ago I was at a certain number you
know many millions and then all of a
sudden I was down over a million and
then I came down I said what's going on
and you checked in and you said they say
they are doing adjustments they say they
don't like some of the people and I
don't have to fake people you know a lot
of people by people I don't want to do
that because first of all if I did it
it's a front-page story all over the
place but I know a lot of people there's
no question about it because I see some
numbers that are phony numbers where
they have these you know many many
millions of followers I say there's no
way because nobody has any interest in
these people
is they have no now Herman Cain they
have interesting okay but they have no
interest in these people they're playing
games they're playing games James Woods
I don't know James but he's an
interesting guy and he's a conservative
guy and he's the stretcher he's tough
but when they want to take him off and
other people like him many in this room
some in this room it's a very very bad
it's a very bad thing so I have many
millions of followers across various
accounts and together everyone in this
room we reach over half a billion
followers that I think that's probably a
low number because one of the things I
get that's a little benefit I'll go
watch like I did Golan Heights I gave
Israel the real credit over and and you
know the Golan Heights and is you're
very important but I gave representation
and the strongest form of the Golan
Heights Israel I talked about it a
little quickly they've been looking at
it for 52 years they've been trying to
get it they couldn't get it they'd have
many summits where people would fly in
talk about the Golan Heights and then
fly out this went on many many summits
it's about a 52 year period I said what
happened they said nothing they fly in
they'd fly out some had beautiful planes
some didn't some probably didn't get
there by plane but they'd have many
summits I said watch I'm going to do
this and I said we recognize the Golan
Heights as being part of Israel it was a
big thing I go watch this boom I press
it and within two seconds we have
breaking news John Roberts of Fox was
over he said we have breaking news
please break it up doesn't matter what
they're talking about John does it he
breaks it up
now that's Twitter that's social media I
call Twitter a typewriter that's what I
really call to her because it goes on to
Facebook automatically and it goes on to
Instagram and it goes on to television
more so Fox than it does CNN if it's
something bad they'll put it on
if I have a spelling deal they will put
it on this Donald Trump spelled the word
though wrong you know he doesn't know
how to spell da he spelled it thi you
know I couldn't get any kind of a
punctuation mistake they put it on so
I'm very very careful like really I'm
actually a good speller but everyone
said that the fingers aren't as good as
the brain but but it is true and it's
it's incredible what it does I put out a
social media statement and I was telling
Kellyanne the other day I said you know
I used to put out like a press release
right and people would pick it up sort
of you know next day two days they'd
find it sitting on a desk if I put out
we hardly do press releases anymore
because if I put out on social media a
statement like I'm going to in a little
while on something totally unrelated but
a very important statement now they're
going crazy what is tell me watch but
it's very very important but if I put
that out in a press release
I'm telling you Kevin people don't pick
it up it's me same if I put it out on
social media it's like an explosion Fox
CNN crazy MSNBC they're stone cold crazy
I made them a lot of money with The
Apprentice and I gave him a top show
when they were dying on NBC but they
don't like me too much they wanted a big
extension they used Arnold
Schwarzenegger instead big movie star
you know what he died he died I was
there twelve twelve years fourteen
seasons and then they pick a movie actor
and he dies on us you know I own that
with with Mark Burnett and some people
what I said they said would you rather
have him had been like this tremendous
massive success you own it so you
benefit financially or would you rather
have him die so that you say you did it
for 14 seasons 12 years I said I think
I'd rather have him die at it
that means you don't need the money I'd
rather have them die at it anyway but
with amazing creativity and
determination you're bypassing the
corrupt establishment and it is corrupt
and you're bypassing the very very
corrupt media which not all of it is but
much of it is far greater percentages
and anyone would understand as the
cameras start to go off they go the red
lights look well I can always tell I can
always tell like when I talk about and
I'll be in the stadium the red lights
are roll on everyone's guy and then we
start talking about like the media how
dishonest it is how corrupt it is how
fake it is and you see lights going off
lights immediately go off and usually
they don't come back they said this
guy's impossible but I want to just say
because you people have a lot of courage
to each and every one of you I say thank
you very much on behalf of a nation
thank you very much it's very important
what you're doing you're getting the
beginning in many cases the honest word
not in all cases but in many cases when
historians look back at this time they
will see that many of the biggest news
stories of our era
we're totally ignored I I can tell you
that I deal with the media and the spin
they put on it or sometimes they'll
leave it out and then if there's
something slightly negative they'll make
it you know headline news they'll put it
down as headline news or even covered up
by the media of they were broken up by
citizens and you can take a look at
what's happening and you see stories
that should be phenomenal big beautiful
stories and it turns out that they don't
get covered we did something yesterday
on kidney and kidney dialysis and
there's a tremendous number of people
with problems with kidneys then it was
secretary Hayes there was a big big
important thing that very little
coverage you know very positive what we
did is such a great thing I don't care
we don't have to get the it's good for
our nation it's good for people to read
about it and see the strides that we've
made of what we're doing but that
doesn't get covered and it should get
covered and it doesn't get covered for a
reason because they don't want to give
that
to a conservative they don't want to let
that happen now
if somebody else were in this position
such as the previous administration
didn't make that headline news all over
the place what we did yesterday but when
we're doing it they give very little
credit to that but anything bad that
happens I always say they could take bad
and make it horrible they can take a
good story and make it sort of bad and
they can take a great great story and
make it anywhere from good your to
slightly bad it's incredible what they
can do I say I haven't had a good story
in two and a half years I used to get
great press Steve bernucci knows he said
mean you get the greatest press until I
got elected then it's tough but I used
to get the greatest press possibly what
are the reasons I'm here but we we're
getting the word out and we get it out
in a different way I didn't think would
have to Charlie I didn't think it would
be this tough and by the way two very
special people I have to say hello to
him because my wife said I see these two
beautiful women african-american
incredible women that are a television
they are unbelievable this is two years
ago she was before her time they have no
idea who I'm talking about she was our
first land he said you have to see these
women they're incredible they're genius
and they like you I said I want to see
them and I like them I love them
actually I love them
[Applause]
[Applause]
so when the historians look back they're
gonna see something very important took
place right here before today it took
place it started taking place a number
of years ago and it's something that
nobody ever thought would happen free
speech is a bedrock of American life our
constitutional rights must be fiercely
protected and I want you to know that we
will always have you back we're fighting
for you very hard we're gonna be calling
a big meeting of the companies for in a
week or two they have to be here and
Josh is really leading a very strong
group of people this isn't just Josh
this is you leading a tremendous group
and they feel equally as strongly as you
because they see the unfairness of
what's happening and remember we won we
have a bigger voice than anybody but we
don't get covered fairly can you imagine
if we were covered fairly we had our
best polls like yesterday they were
telling me I said could you imagine if I
actually got good press instead of even
fair press I don't want good I want fair
can you imagine what those numbers would
be they make up story you know the
Russian hoax I call it the Russian hoax
the witch hunt all bad publicity and yet
we're doing great in the polls so people
understand that the public is very smart
but we're getting the word out about so
many things not just that about so many
things and maybe the most important
thing about how great our country's
doing jobs now more people working today
than ever in the history of our country
ever in the history of our country think
of that unemployment are the best
numbers in 51 years for African American
the best numbers in our history in our
history Herman
[Applause]
including you and you're making a lot I
hope but hispanic-american best numbers
in history and I like your dresses by
the way very much no not you sir you
thank you
I saw you the other day fantastic job
but hispanic-american the best in
history Asian American the best in
history women I think Kelly and the best
in 75 years the best in best
unemployment of business in 75 years
what we're doing it's nothing like his
this has been our military is now strong
when I took it over was depleted we had
planes that were so old they didn't fly
they'd have to go to the desert to get
parts when we took it over it was not a
good situation we got seven hundred
billion dollars then 716 billion and
we're gonna be asking for another one
this year and it's all manufactured in
the United States we make it ourselves
and that's always good because that's
jobs now in this case jobs aren't
important compared to military defense
but we make the best planes and rockets
and military equipment anywhere in the
world nothing like it and we're doing
something that's incredible so our
military is strong our our country is
really powerful and really strong never
been like this what's how did it fly get
into the White House I don't like I
don't like flies I don't like flies so I
just want to tell you just in finishing
up we had a terrible bias we have
censorship like nobody has any
understanding or nobody can believe when
you see the Google executives together
and one of their executives decides to
put it on the phone right that's right
thank you there he is
stand up please how good
[Applause]
what a great job somebody said he's
controversies he's not controversial
he's truthful
he's truthful that was a great that was
one of many thank you thank you very
much fantastic so you know they're
playing with with a lot of minds and
they're playing unfairly and the funny
thing is that
you
freedom far more you see what's
happening up on the debate stand you see
what they're doing to each other you're
seeing the hatred that they have up
there and it's a very different
philosophy it's a very different thought
and I'll say this the election that's
coming up is I think and you know we
talk 2016 and I would say maybe that's
the most important and certainly I said
it but what we're really fighting for
there has never been a difference of of
this candidate our candidate your
candidate against whoever it may be
there will never be anything like that
hopefully again because what they're
looking at is pure socialism or worse
than socialism you know there's a word
called communism - there's a word good
they don't like to use it very rarely do
you hear that but there's a word called
communism and they're trying to get
socialism over the line but these people
are this is beyond socialism to a large
extent and I think that we're gonna have
a tremendous success we had a sort of an
opening rally in Orlando Florida we had
a hundred and nine thousand maybe more
that was done wanting to come we were
doing as much as we could to keep people
not from coming we have a 21,000 seat
stadium and then with the basketball
court it held many more than that it was
packed and we had a similar number
outside and we had thousands and
thousands of people that wanted to be
there and this was an opening and you
look at Biden they say he had six
hundred people that wasn't six hundred
there was a hundred and fifty people
that was a very small crowd and even
their big friends I mean if they have a
thousand people it's like a big crowd
we have enthusiasm that's far greater
than the left it's not even a contest
they don't want to say that they never
will say that we had on the mall just
the other day fourth of July a
tremendous success it was pouring the
weather was just it was beautiful in one
way they learned it was my real hair
that day because I was drenched well
that is the one good thing I ran and
they learned it's my hair because I've
been through every windstorm sandstorm
let's go over here let's go this one
that one this desert let's go to this
ocean and get out of the plane sir the
wind is blowing at about 70 miles an
hour I said boy it's got to be it's got
to be mind but but we've seen it all
we've seen it all and I've tell you what
more than anything else I've met great
people I've met great people dedicated
people and I think that the election
coming up Kevin this is the most
important election of our times this is
election where our country is gonna go
one way or it's going to head in the
direction of Venezuela and that's what's
gonna happen that's what's gonna happen
this green new deal and and you know I
hate to speak badly of it right now
because it's a little early I spoke too
early on Elizabeth
Pocahontas Warren I spoke I should have
saved it but you know what so I don't
like to go too early because I don't
want him to change I like the green new
deal I want them to keep going I don't
want them to make it but you know the
problem with this business they can make
a change and immediately upon making
that list for about a week you look at
for instance on the wall chuck schumer
was totally in favor of a wall right Liz
totally in favor
everybody Hilary everybody they were all
in favor of a wall just a few years ago
now a wall is a well that's okay they
want open borders they want people to
pour in including criminals the worst
criminals they want people to pour into
our country nobody can tell me that's
good
politically nobody can tell
so all Americans regardless of their
political beliefs or affiliations
they've got a right to speak their mind
that includes them then it eludes them
but they don't have the same difficulty
they don't get shut out I wrote a few
terms I said to my son down who's here
somewhere are you done are you done good
Kimberly Don
people like Don thank you them but but
we wrote out of shadow ban 100% you look
you
that they don't let them join they don't
there was there's no doubt in my mind
that I should have millions and millions
I have millions of people so many people
I wouldn't believe it but I know that
we've been blocked people come up to me
and they say sir I can't I can't get you
I can't follow you they make it
impossible these are people that are
really good at what they do they say
they make it absolutely impossible and
you know we can't have it we're not
gonna let it happen Josh we're not gonna
let it happen and you know if they did
it on both sides if it were done to the
other side to the other group and I'm
representing everybody I do I represent
everybody I fully understand liberal I
fully understand Democrat we want to get
along we want to make sure that
everybody loves each other if that's
possible and maybe I really believe it
is something it will be I have said that
the thing that's gonna bring us together
is great success now we have tremendous
success greater than we've ever had
before I mean our country picked up
trillions of dollars in value and worth
China's gone down trillions of dollars
to tariffs have hurt him I don't want to
hurt him but I want them to give us a
player a fair playing field but China's
gone down trillions we've gone up rignot
billions trillions we've gone up in
value and worth I want everybody to do
well but they've got to treat us fairly
they've got to treat everybody has to be
treated fairly their side our side we
all have to be treated fairly and you
know the farmers say we just want a
level playing field sir
I love the farmers they're Patriots and
China as you know targeted the farmers
because they think they could get to me
by hurting the people that I love and
that we take care of and had no impact I
would watch even on networks that don't
exactly like me and I'd watch as they
interview farmers and that have 10 or 12
people sitting where they say we don't
care the president's right we've been
ripped off for many years somebody has
to do somebody had to do this China made
over the last 10 years hundreds of
billions of dollars you could say four
to five hundred billion dollars a year
that's not sustained
we built China and you know what they've
done a great job I don't blame them I
blame our former presidents and the
leaders of our country for allowing this
to go on
ever since the World Trade Organization
opened up they allowed this to go on
they allowed hundreds of billions of
dollars a year to be taken out of our
country and to be used to rebuild China
so those days are over so right now
they're paying 25% of 250 billion
dollars a lot of money coming in you
know we had a 3.2 GDP for the first
quarter everyone saying when the hell
that happened because first quarters the
weakest quarter always almost almost
always and we had like this great
quarter but I don't consider 3.0 grade I
consider much higher and frankly if we
had lower interest rates you know we're
forced to pay more money than other
countries because we have a rate that's
high we have somebody that likes raising
rates now I think he's maybe gonna
change but we'll find out but if we had
lower we'd have another 10,000 points
where do we just set a record you know
I'm a very greedy person we just set a
record 27,000 I said we could be 10,000
points higher we could be 10,000 because
there's no inflation big thing is
inflation there's no inflation but we're
doing so well we're gonna keep it that
way so I just want to introduce because
a person that I've admired for a long
time who's a great lawyer Harmeet Dillon
and she's one of the leading First
Amendment lawyers in our country and her
me could you come up just say a few
words please thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president it's a
tremendous honor to be here with a lot
of people who I really respect and
admire the corrupt establishment that
you talked about and the mainstream
media have told a lot of people in this
room that the social media censorship of
the banning that we're experiencing is
all in our heads they're gaslighting us
with this lie let me tell you about a
couple of people I represented my law
practice and the civil rights work that
we do David Horowitz is a great American
who was a supporter of yours and has
been in the movement for many decades
well Twitter abruptly D platformed him
one day took him off said he was banned
and then he complained and then they let
him back on and then the next day they
did the exact same thing to him that's
not an accident James d'amour is another
great American who I represent mr.
demora complained internally about
Google's discriminatory practices
against conservatives and pushed for
more balance not only was he fired for
daring to do that but then these social
media platforms use their platforms to
humiliate him publicly weaponize their
platforms and make sure that he could
not get a job in Silicon Valley that's a
disgrace but it goes beyond that these
social media CEOs have come to Congress
in front of many of these member of
Congress here and they've lied about
what they do they lied about the data
theft they lied about the media
manipulation and they can't get away
with that now senator Blackburn knows
from what happened to her on Twitter
that these companies are trying to stop
the ordinary men and women who you
represent from hearing their voices I'm
very concerned that they affected the
outcome of the 2018 election and if we
let them do what they're going to do
what they've been doing it's going to
affect the outcome of the 2020 election
as well so mr. president thank you so
much for inviting everybody here to talk
about these issues and we're all behind
you joining the fight to make sure that
every American's voice is heard thank
you very much
and what Harmeet said is so so true I
mean it's it's really incredible you
know I've watched and I've watched some
of these scenes that have been taped and
gotten through talented people by the
way but gotten through and gotten to the
public where you see the hatred of of
our party of our people of our voice and
you say that's the collusion
it's a collusion between the Democrats
and the media and and social media and
these platforms it's a it's a
disgraceful thing and another thing I
believe you're representing a young man
who just got slugged viciously slugged I
think it's a disgrace you ever noticed
they pick on certain people I mean he
would tell you he's not the toughest
person in the world physically right
they don't go after bikers for Trump
never noticed that they don't go after
our construction workers who love us
they don't go after the police they
don't go after we have incredible people
you know we're the elite
they say they relief you know would you
ever hear this hey I live better than
all of them great education the greatest
houses the quick but I guess I'm not
elite they live like in the basement of
their mom's home their arms are this big
look like this but they have the black
they have the black masks on and they
have sticks and they hit people they hit
people in the face in the head this
anti-fur but you ever notice antepers
never there when we have a bikers rally
they're never there when the
construction workers and the unions are
honoring the president they're never
around they're always there when you
have a single guy protesting in front of
a school and as you probably know I
think all of you know we did something
very serious I signed an executive order
recently we're taking money away from
those schools we're gonna you know we
give them billions and billions of
dollars and they don't allow priests
and we don't want anything special but
we want free speech we're also joined by
someone affected by this troubling by us
very very much and president of
live-action and somebody I've watched
really with great admiration Lila please
come up Lila Rose thank you so much mr.
president it's really an honor to be
here thank you for doing this important
summit
I represent live action I'm the founder
and president and we are a pro-life
organization which reaches millions of
people every week with the truth about
abortion and human dignity we have been
for four years banned from doing any
advertising on Twitter and they told us
that an order to reinstate her accounts
we'd have to stop calling for the
defunding of Planned Parenthood and stop
sharing her pro-life content meanwhile
Planned Parenthood and other abortion
groups continued to advertise last month
we were permanently suspended from
Pinterest and they accused us of
spreading conspiracy theories and
misinformation with their pro-life
content with no evidence and then news
media groups picked up the narrative and
spread it around meanwhile abortion
groups including abortion clinics post
freely on Pinterest and then recently
our videos have been viewed more more
highly than almost any other abortion
related content on YouTube but YouTube
we met to the first page of search
results but YouTube buried our pro-life
videos and boosted pro-abortion videos
so this double standard and bias is a
growing problem in big tech even though
they say that they are politically
neutral and they don't discriminate they
even testified before Congress and said
that so thank you so much to the
administration to you mr. president for
holding this very important summit
thank you
[Applause]
so one of the advantages of being
president is when you ask for meeting
you get it generally I don't know I
can't think of two Bini I haven't gotten
and you say I'd like to see in the Oval
Office or you have somebody call Oval
Office I've been with all of these
people at the highest level one-on-one
just recently with Google and just
recently with Twitter the top right and
you talk to them and you swear they're
like your best friend Oh sir
no we're we believe we've freedom of
speech well yes absolutely and we go out
he's like who said that must come from
Queens so so it's very interesting to
see that and and the level of you know
you look at me just sincerity and I say
that's fantastic and they leave and then
I'll realize three or four weeks later
it's worse actually got worse because I
say look I believe in technology I
believe in free markets I believe in
freedom of speech I believe it all the
things and and they are super genius I
tell you I'm dealing with China and they
admitted there's nobody like Silicon
Valley does nobody smart in that sense
maybe not smart in other senses have
watch some of them speak before Congress
it's not pretty I say I could do much
better than that but I tell you what
technologically it's unbelievable what
they think even Dan and I when we sat
with you-know-who at Twitter number one
we talked about certain things he said
yeah we could do this I said that's
really right you know this is China will
admit this nobody like these brains but
they're not using that brilliance and
they're not using what we gave them
fairly and they have to do that and we
don't want to stifle anything we
certainly don't want to stifle free
speech but that's no longer free speech
see I don't think that the mainstream
media's free speech
because it's so crooked it's so
dishonest so to me free speech is not
when you see something good and then you
purposely write bad to me that's very
dangerous speech and you become angry at
it but that's not free speech somebody
came to my office I won't say he'll but
a very big person and I said okay you
don't like the term take news which I
think I get credit for but I'm sure if I
said I get credit they'll say 13 years
ago somebody came up with a term fake I
think I get credit I'd be very proud to
take it but I think I get could now by
the way the worst fakers of all are
using fake news I saw the other day on
CNN total fakes I see on CNN they go
fake news media has reported don't know
they're fake there's baby they've turned
it around so I'm not going to allow and
Josh and all of us were just not going
to allow it to happen like this we're
not going to be silenced two months ago
we created a new White House tool to
report social media bias censorship and
discrimination we saw you folks being
taken off and we fought on all of you
and many of you are back now but many of
the names I won't mention your name so
some some of you were taking off for
absolutely no reason I mean an or for
some of you I could almost understand it
I mean some of you guys are out there
but even you should have a voice but
some of you now some of you deserve I
mean it's genius but it's bad but they
take off people that you know that you
wouldn't believe and we received over
16,000 responses just in a tiny little
period of time talking about this
subject based on the feedback that we're
hearing from you I'm announcing that we
will ask representatives of the major
social media platforms to join me at the
White House over the next month have a
big meeting and a real conversation with
what might want to invite some of you I
know Josh wouldn't have you and some of
the Senators and it's amazing how the
senators including Democrats in all
fairness which is probably because they
know can turn on them also it can turn
very quickly but they want to come so
we'll let you know the day okay and
today I'm directing my administration to
explore all regulatory and legislative
solutions to protect free speech and the
free speech rights of all Americans
that's you people in this room and a lot
of people out there and a lot of people
we hope to see transparency more
accountability and more freedom and so
on both sides this is not I am NOT
speaking for our side assuming we're oh
I don't even know if you're on our side
he could be some of the most liberal
people in the world in this audience and
that's okay I don't care but we're
talking about for everybody big tech
must not censor the voices of the
American people to all of these social
media influencers here today a lot of
you have a lot of power and you have a
lot of strength and you know you have to
use it wisely many of you do but you
have to I want to thank you once again
for being here you're very special
people you're very brilliant people in
so many cases I look around the room I
mean I see people that really have
almost found a new life over the last
short period of time with this new
technology but this new technology is so
powerful and so important and it has to
be used fairly has to be used fairly so
thank you all for being
here it's a great honor tremendous honor
we're gonna take a few questions I think
and then I'll head out and you're gonna
actually come if you want you can come
to the great rose garden you can stand
in the rain with me we're going to talk
a little bit about the fact that we're
not allowed to ask for whether or not
somebody's a citizen on the census form
and I think we have a solution that will
be very good for a lot of people really
good okay any questions please Oh
arias
but yeah how's your new show going good
very well I heard good thank you
yes indeed America first